スーパーのもの全部買って家をスーパーに
してほしいコンビニで600万かかった
からスーパーわー
6000万くらいかな
考えとくねこれじゃあ肇社長ですよねここ
東京のお部屋の一つなんですけどもまぁ
いわゆる編集ベイトがゲーム部屋と呼んで
いる場所なんですけどもまぁこちらが編集
ですね東京で動画編集する時はここの
パソコンを使ってるんですけどさっき
ゲーム配信試してるんですけどもゲーム
配信設備から完成したんですよ
はいこちらでございます
[音楽]
ん
持っ機材の晩に詳しくないので事務所の
機材詳しい人に手伝っていただいて結構
色々買って設備を整えたんですけども金
ないとば設備はすごいんですけどもゲーム
実況する時には一つ
決定よ見つけてしまいまして何かというと
ちょっと叫ぶねああああ
わー
響くんじゃ思ったより響いてしまってるん
ですよ声が無難か私も経験あるんですけど
もなんかレコーディングする部屋とか
ゲーム実況者さんがやって吸音材と言わ
れるですねその音の微ハウリング d が
響きを消す壁に貼る素材みたいなやつが
あるんですけども各実況設備がちゃんと
できたので俺もなんか生配信たくさんし
たいなと思って自分の生配信昔の ok
結構声が響いてだからなおそうだと思い
まして
10どんななかった吸音材買いました
これでいいこちらですめっちゃ圧縮され
てるからの頭大きいはず
ええええええ
teeはぁっ
[音楽]
2ん
ます
なぜ海外から届いだこういうライトも孝行
をし回収できて弾削ら員や6月会いでぇ
はい活気が下手くそ僕も実もなどテープで
ぐるぐる巻きにされていない全員ですよ
安全に運びいただくほどよそれは開けると
ちょっと大変だなと思いますねそれも出て
きましたなんか剥がさマッシュのだからさ
イメージをガラッと変えようと思って結構
しっかり色のついた吸音材買わせて
いただきました
[音楽]
t
ana
対象だ釣ればよか持ってればいいんだっ
たらさあ圧縮されているのでとても小さい
ですがめちゃくちゃたくさん飛びました
そして色はレッド
声ねに
6ないはいするポイントですね6周28
24をれためっちゃ牛久慣れてるから
あげると超つかなかったこれ密封されてい
てぺちゃんこだったんで国家らーっ
ピラミッド型だこれでも圧縮されてるから
こっからさらに大きくなっていくはずです
あとこれ何か入ってるのはすごいてない5
6まただりすぎん
純受注にまいりニールよ
48倍
あちょっと待ってくださいよ止まれって
書いてあります開封した後24時間マッチ
ます
car
mene
んわー
4 ever スージーズーちょっと話
変わってくるんですけど
あの
3倍あります今見せた数が後にコクがある
ので150枚ぐらいはあるかなあ突如全部
開けないとダメっぽいんで1回あげてこの
枚広げまくって24時間放置してちゃんと
福田んでから集め貼っていこうと思います
綺麗に並べるの部屋が壁に貼る時何で今
とりあえずちゃんと剥がして大きくなるの
をちょっと待とうと思いますはいという
わけで1週間端ましたあんまり東京来る
機会がなかったので放置してるんですけど
もめちゃくちゃ大きくな取り上げもっと
薄い種少なかったのに2.5倍ぐらいの量
になったんですけども2種類ありますね形
がこの館に涙目なやつと
ギザギザのちょっとのロックな感じで時間
だって相当厚みが出たのでこれは常に貼り
まくればおそらく最高のゲーム環境実況が
でき捧ぐ貼っていきましょう
草
ある意味あるい
快適で早速この響き枕部屋着吸音材貼って
行きたいと思いますそのビューもあったの
たびに声で出させてください白梅の部屋の
響きです
あーげー占拠してをこんな感じ
ああああわあ
パワー
壁のことは知りません退去の時考えます
貼っていきましょう ok ok ok
落ち着いて走りますありまーあります
会え退去比較で大悦
ちょっ
とずっずサーガ
ってる帰化しませんかねこれ
そうなんですねえ刑事ブルボンだーうう
うーーあってもこれでパワー姉はですね
ちょっと不安が残りますがどんどん勝って
いきましょうちょっと分けます
[音楽]
ちょっと
道央
いよいよをもう一歩いっぽい
うあ
ああ
あ
[音楽]
ああ
うわああああああ
[音楽]
ああ
あ
心の何かが痛いと違うスカラボロイ多分
もう何年かすると凹凸ずくらいの柔らかさ
なるほどペチャッ立ってる感じああ
[音楽]
今日はここまでん
ああ今日は8日目ですどんなボンドは全く
壁につかなかったので改めてスポンジが
つくであろう料別途かかりました出窓段
ボールでしっかり覆って遊びも95際
晴れるようでしたのでこれでもかなりマッ
カーディアンが作れると思いますやって
いきましょう
福はー
ん
[音楽]
まだわからないマーサーまだわからあり
ますん
th
あぁはぁまぁちょっと貼るだけやって
みようか
[音楽]
今のところめちゃくちゃいいんだよもう
パソはさビッククレーターにあるじゃない
ですかね入っています
街待ってたらくっつけたこれ
ね駄目だりダメならばたかったすべき
分けるそれっ
味わいすごいなーっ
エディックデーエロや言えはあなたは救急
車 runaway d 4 ea 2 a
で起きてる
[音楽]
moon
ん
ね88日目なんですけれども強力でたんで
テープですが眼鏡くっつかないネット動画
を調べていい軽装備なのか書いてあったん
ですけどもそれではちょっとぶりだったん
で8日も飽きられますと仕事があるので
静岡に帰ります
ど1週間ぶりに行きましたというわけで見
てください全部上がれてまあそれも物理的
に普通のテープ粘着テープ接着剤4つの
メリットということが我々もうこの3週間
ほど使ってこれ何日目もうさすがに終止符
を打ちたいということで今回こちら
ホワイトでグッズ本神様協力両名きテープ
普通の両面テープではつきにくかった
スポンジフェルト布を発砲するなど簡単に
接着できます勝ちましたというでまずは
本当につくかどうかを確かめたいそれ次第
ねこんな企画てるからねこれが無駄になる
かならないか決まります借りすぎました
いきますあぁなんかだか強そうだぞこれ見
てくれも色が今までちれんだ
ちょっと黄色椅子なんかじゃ何してもいい
頃ああ
何などはダボレッセンスでは行きます
次いでぐん
えっ
ノートだ
これつよいぞなんかね嫌な音してたけど
強いわおっもう大畔蹄鉄っっケースですよ
ああコンっ
これですわすごいぞこれ
はいそれじゃ
まずですごい一瞬でよお前になんだったん
マジで2時間返してほしいもんじゃなく
じゃあスポーツって何言っ
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
me
can ん
分
ん
うわぁ
というわけでようやくゲーム絶叫するこの
部屋の中御材を貼り終えることができまし
た
同様使うと環境しないようになったと思う
んで結構基地取りやすくなったと思います
こっちがにしゃべると言うこっち側から
しゃべるときですねあ
まあ oo
響かない響かないめっちゃへあとなんかも
調べないんですけど赤い部屋とか赤い色
ってやる気が出るらしくてこっちにある
遊ぶの編集するんで結構赤が目に入って
やる気が出るのかなと思っ色をちょっと
工夫してこの経営を配しビューを作らせて
いただきますまずスポンジを壁に付ける
ことのないで歌なんかマジでは必要強い
拙著財団がボーンとテープでつかなかった
ので普通でも絶望したんでただ世の中には
スポンジ用のテープがあったということで
無事に着くことができました大丈夫が落ち
たよねそれだけちょっと心配なんですけど
なんか時間がどう出るかやめてねまぁ
ちょっといつまでもつのかなという感じで
はありますよね始めたつをツールゲーム
実況をちょっと力入れてやっていきたいな
と思うので是非生配信やったーーー次にて
くる以上今日のメインチャンネルでした
ちゃう
[音楽]
ブーブー言っ
ただいまー
あれから3日がたちません
まだついてたらいいんですけどねさせ鍵穴
で1着ループだったらついてでしょ
えっ